[Musique]
après le vendée globe le tour de france
décidément la vendée n'en finit pas de
parler d'elle cérémonie d'ouverture du
tour de france hier soir sur le site du
puy du fou les formations engagées ont
été présentés devant un nombreux public
[Musique]
fast dans le bocage pour cette épreuve
devenue désormais institutions lavande
et son président nous ont fait un tour à
leurs façons ne manquez pas un bouton de
guêtre 800 bénévoles du spectacle pas un
mollet même des plus prestigieux comme
celui d'eddy merckx le roi de la vendée
présenter la petite reine en grand
apparat
on est très heureux très fier parce que
ce soir la grande aventure du puy-du-fou
rencontre la grande aventure du tour de
france des formidables pour nous moyens
lourds et france2 moyens légers france 3
les 18 équipes du tour de france
cycliste ont salué comme de vrais romain
les 15000 spectateurs du cirque depuis
le presque tout paris télévisuelle était
je suis très heureux et très fier et
c'est vrai que j'aime le cyclisme j'ai
fait du vélo dans ma vie j'en fais
encore maintenant je dirais que c'est le
seul support que je pratique non pas en
compétition j'ai passé l'âge mais parce
que je sais que c'est un sport complet
et je sais que le tour de france aussi
quelque chose qui réunit tous nos
compatriotes
je suis très heureux que france 3 nantes
soit présent subtil mélange des genres
muscles histoire et traditions à
spectacle superbe est bien rodé un
impact médiatique certain toute la
presse sportive en a parlé ou en parlera
est au paradis des libres penseurs le
meilleur d'entre tous les journalistes
le vélo monsieur jadis où antoine
blondin a dû sourire dans sa barque
[Applaudissements]
une cérémonie retransmise ce soir sur
france 2 à partir de 22h30
[Musique]